most people it seems at least on the
left
are quite sure that um that now the
protests will stop
and while it's only today that
most of the media have declared a winner
um i don't see any evidence that the
riots anyway
put aside the protests because really
they they are related
phenomena but but very often it's quite
clear when you're talking about riots
and not protests
are not stopping at all so um let me
just provide a few examples
here hold on um go back and forth a few
times
we have uh
the pacific northwest youth liberation
front saying [ __ ] trump [ __ ] biden death
to america
we want something better than this trash
and we're going to take it
so that was the evening the late evening
of the election
wait scroll over on that one to the next
image
whoever they vote for we are
ungovernable ungoverned yeah
yep yep this is so next sec thank you
um there's just a better picture of that
here whoever they vote for we are
ungovernable
with the signs of anarchy okay zach
um let's see
this we don't want biden we want revenge
for police murders imperialist wars and
fascist massacres
and maybe um
if they've got a lot of remain
ungovernable
uh let's see the fight continues
post-election protest the fight
continues
we don't know what the fight is about
even at this point we're just being told
the fight continues
um and of course what we s what we've
been seeing in portland
still every night since the election is
more vandalism there is a church
in downtown portland here we go is
multnomah county sheriff reporting on
this church
that was doing tremendous work with
homeless which of course
portland has a huge problem with um
being vandalized sufficiently that they
have now declared that the church itself
can no longer be doing some of its work
with the homeless because the church is
not intact enough to do so
and then let me just one more example of
this
here's nancy roman our friend who was in
portland
for several days this week who
was present to see for instance the wild
fang
basically a feminist women's fashion
store
had all of its windows blown out and
um and and many and many other
things like that so i highly recommend
this article in reason if
if you haven't read it by nancy realman
so
they're they and who is they it's you
know it's a tiny fringe element among
the people who were who were in fact
protesting peacefully
of course right um for for many many
months
but it's not a tiny fringe part of those
people who started rioting
reliably every night after dark for many
many months here in portland
and why is it
that they haven't changed their tune now
that the election has actually come to
pass well because it's not
actually responsive to its environment
this is not activism that is responsive
to its environment
therefore it should both not be taken
seriously
i would say as a critique of particular
policies or politicians
but it is being taken seriously you know
mayor wheeler who we
triumphantly re-elected because by doing
so we avoided the actual antifa
candidate
um mayor wheeler and uh governor brown
who this week has been making some moves
in i think the correct direction
um but have been taking these people
seriously with their
batshit demands as if they are actually
responding
to policy and people and
at the same time as we should not be
taking their critique
as if it is actually about policy or
people given that they are telling us
it's not
we should also be taking it far more
seriously than it is as a force of
destruction and not just of windows
and not even just of individual acts of
violence of which there is plenty of
evidence
but an actual force of destruct
destruction i could not find
the couple of images that i'd seen
earlier in the week from denver and i
think from philly
which have them arguing that liberalism
itself is the enemy
death to america yeah well that's that's
the thing is that
this is a an attack on
the very fabric of pluralistic
secular society and if you pay attention
to what it says and what it does this is
very
clear now what it has gotten good at is
reversing cause and effect so the fact
that you have a large
number of you know chardonnay
liberals with trump derangement syndrome
those people are susceptible
to partnering with anything that appears
to be equally angry about the thing that
has their focus
and so you know the whole thing that we
watched go down in slow motion here
in portland was the relentless
attack on policing and
governance and authority that forced
trump
at the federal level to bring in uh dhs
officers which then was portrayed as the
precipitating event for the violence
and the point is cause and effect have
been reversed
what it is that is being sought by these
protesters and rioters is quite clear in
what they say they're not good at
keeping it under wraps but somebody
paying casual attention or worse
somebody editing what it is that others
see can very easily portray it in the
wrong direction so that it appears to be
a reaction to something
that they themselves find find
troubling i will say at first i was very
heartened to hear
governor brown's uh bringing in of the
national guard and the fact that
finally we saw a proportionate response
to the violence
where there were so just just to just to
provide some details
she declared a state of emergency in the
state of oregon from
5 pm the day before election day through
wednesday 5 pm
uh and basically allowed the possibility
that the national guard would come
in and that they and i think it was
multnomah county
which is the main uh county uh that
portland
is in uh would have the authority to use
tear gas such that the you know the
non-lethal means that had been taken off
the table by
mayor wheeler would now be back on the
table such that perhaps we could
actually avoid
you know state-promoted violence while
also
actually keeping the peace and um in the
wake of the
riots both election night and basically
promises to continue at the next night
she is now conti she has now extended
that um i don't know if it's officially
the state of emergency or just
all of the stuff around the national
guard through at least tomorrow
through at least sunday and very much to
her credit and so doing she did not
make the usual move that uh we've seen
in so many
democratic municipalities and and other
uh other uh provinces and the like but
she said we won't tolerate violence from
the left from the right
or the center that was her phrase and uh
anyway it was well done
overdue inexplicably but nonetheless
done and done before the election
um so uh you know good on you governor
brown
very much so um yeah the other thing
though is
we were of course very uh concerned
about
the fact that mayor wheeler was facing
this challenge from sarah iannarone
uh to his nominal left
and she was a not so cryptic supporter
of antifa so that was a very frightening
prospect
that she might win now she lost which i
initially took to be
a good sign that reason had won out and
as much as
wheeler has been a spectacular
disappointment is an understatement to
say the very least
he stood a greater chance of ultimately
coming to his senses and standing up to
this nonsense that is threatening
his city and its citizens but what i
found out later
was that in fact there had been a
substantial
write-in campaign now nobody because of
the way the ballots are reported we
cannot say whose name was written
in but the only plausible candidate to
have
taken to have gotten as many write-in
votes
um was actually somebody understood to
be
even to the nominal left of iannarone
a founder of the group don't shoot
portland
so it is not clear at all why ted
wheeler
won and whether that was an outbreak of
reason or the result
of a divided vote on the um
i hesitate to i'm going to not use an
epithet
i'm going to say the extreme illiberal
left
but um but in any case the right outcome
did happen that right outcome is still
uh very little security in light of what
wheeler has allowed but well and here we
have
wheeler today i am grateful to be mayor
of a city that overwhelmingly voted for
joe biden and kamala harris
we can now move forward instead of
fighting against an administration that
tried to move us backward
we now will have a partner in the
federal government instead of an
opponent
here he is reversing cause and effect
willfully
confusedly who knows i don't
i don't think he's a dumb man so um
it's possible that he is legitimately
confused or he really
you know or he saw exactly the threat
that you saw went like wow
um actually half the people who voted in
portland more than half the people who
voted in portland i think
um voted for either someone who actively
supports antifa or someone even farther
left than her
um i don't like this description of
that's being left
left yeah um even more liberal than her
and is imagining that those of us who
voted
for him will put up with anything and
all he has to do is keep on moving more
and more liberal
and uh one thing that i think you know
most
the vast majority of people who watch us
and listen to us aren't in portland but
um i cannot imagine that
uh the next time the mayor of portland
is
up for re-election um that the vast
majority of us who still live here
however many of us that might be at that
point
will be paying such insignificant
attention that we allow
this kind of diabolical choice to show
up on the ballot again
well uh so the problem of course
is that i think people are
voting and signaling as if this is
all an abstraction and it is very
obvious that it will not take long if
you allow
a force to break the windows of whatever
businesses it wants and to terrorize
citizens the way
the rioters have been doing night after
night
if you allow people to do this it is
obviously going to
destroy the economic base of the city
you know
uh it's not a place that somebody's
going to want to
start a business if there are no
businesses then
where is the tax base right so
you know people are voting in a way that
completely up ends the capacity of the
city to be governed well
now you know to the extent that there's
a defense
for you know a liberally minded city
it's you want one that is capable of
accomplishing things that others can't
you want
you know better transportation you want
you know
safer cleaner streets you you know you
want the city to function well and in
fact that's the slogan portland is the
city that works
right is that right oh i didn't know
that yeah that's amazing
right but the thing is it's very easy to
upend that
and then the point is everybody's worse
off and so
whatever your liberal values have you
pursuing you've undone
them by virtue of the fact that there's
nothing to do those things with yeah
well so just a couple more minutes on
portland on
politics that are local to us here there
is something
um something good that happened um
that is an actual positive as opposed to
a
you know very much a lesser of two evils
which is the situation with the
mayoral race in portland um but i'm
going to start with something that's
uh definitely not so good um why won't
it open
um okay well i can't open that site for
some reason
okay um so city commissioner um dan ryan
i'm trying to open this link from well
i'm at week
um and zach's going to try to open it
for me but now i can't read my notes
um so dan ryan who was an extant
city commissioner and who was not being
being who's not
on the ballot this this year voted
against an 18 million
cut to the police budget and a mob came
to his house in the middle of the night
and vandalized it and put up flares in
front and this is in part what prompted
governor brown to say actually we're
extending the
um the either the emergency order at
least parts of it then
allow the national guard and the
multnomah county sheriff's office to
um oversee and um give more power to
the portland police bureau so i actually
don't need that anymore zach
i i'm done talking about it um so i need
my screen back though
please so that i can go to the next one
um so that's all
terrible but what isn't terrible is
this we had this commissioner-elect
mingus maps who is a former political
science professor
who is black who is um you know they
call him conservative but what that
means in portland i actually have no
idea
um uh he uh won
against incumbent chloe utilie who was
very much
in line with sort of ian around and
hardesty and
some of the other like actually get rid
of the police
people uh has um
stood up already like he's he's just a
commissioner elect and yet somehow
uh he was allowed to also vote against
the 18 million dollar
uh defunding of the police that happened
uh this week
and he says
this campaign of intimidation and
vandalism against commissioner ryan must
stop
map said mobs have descended on his
house in the middle of the night in
order to intimidate him into voting the
way they want it happened again last
night that's true it happened two nights
running
a mob descended on his house broke
windows and sprayed paint on his home
maps was joined on a press call by about
a dozen black community leaders
his remarks were significant in part
because they signaled a new dynamic in
city hall
a black man will be among the most
conservative members of the council
and he is wielding the language of civil
rights and equity to condemn the
excesses
of a protest movement that also says it
is seeking racial justice
well how [ __ ] lilia that's that's
amazing that is amazing i
this is one of the few things that
actually really gives me hope right now
from this election
yeah i agree that's a um a
a rare but unambiguous sign of reason
[Music]
you